it's Hues of paloa two this season I'll be
without one team member tonight the Devils
will take on Vancouver without the services
of Jack Hughes we still have a match up of two
phenomenal Hughes Brothers Quinn the captain
of the kuu in town against his little brother
Luke Luke's a special player he's really gifted
offensively and defensively almost impossible to
beat cuz he sticks so long and his sketing so good
so he's going to be a top defender in the league
for a long time he's an unbelievable player we're
going have to you know play them hard and play a
bunch of those guys really hard so we got our
hands full tonight and uh we got to bring our
game when the boys played in Vancouver it was
just Jim and I and we have so many family and
friends in the New York metropolitan area and
it brings everybody together and they want to
be a part of it we went to a lot of Youth ranks
watching them play growing up never expecting
them to be in the NHL I think our count was close
to 70 people there and hopefully we see a great
game tonight okay boys it's be a real good for
check in line tonight make sure we stop in battles
keep your feet moving cut backs find the holes
little quick strikes let's have a great effort
tonight boys let's go tonight let's go here short
chips start right off the bat here getting Pucket
funnel Pucket let's get people there let's go
win this thing here we go hey guys we're good
here here we go boys smart
Haw here leave it leave it
yeah this right strong on it strong on it rip rib
play yeah yeah yeah let Swit Swit Swit
shoot the puck boys here's a chance in
front the kucks have had a couple of great
a scoring chances we got to go back we got
to be hard on pucks we got to want the
puck we got to come to the puck come
on well we're better than this final 15
seconds of this first period those Devils
have had to weather an onslaught here from
Vancouver but they have done it so far J
boes Here Comes Quinn Hughes the can Captain yeah
the pass comes to heric Long Shot tipped in Le as
Pon 41 seconds into the second period opens the
scoring for Vancouver boys don't turn down shots
boys hes in the blue line one in front TI by
besser Miller on the rebound scores go turn on
a shot job boys job oh boy huggy the Canucks with
a powerful start here to the second have open up a
two nothing lead Anderson for Miller right Circle
one timer he scores and just like that it's three
nothing knucks nice pass 40 three goals here and
a little more than three minutes and Vancouver is
surging ahead We're Half in right now let's go
we're better than that come on let's go come on
no time off here let's get going come on finish me
here's Luke Hughes starting up his brother Quinn
has three points in this game almost oh there's
one to get the devil back it Miller boms away
from the Blue Line Nico Hy we got to get going
here got to get going we got to get going come
on one thing we've never seen this Devil's team
do is they don't quit they play hard they don't
never think they're out of it we're one shot away
one shot away from tighten this thing right up
desper Brat's got it final push for the Devils 25
seconds to go in the period he picks out Eric h
it's a one goal Game Challenge Accepted Garland
back into the devil Z ref he scores with 10
seconds left to the period Conor Garland
answers back for the Canucks it's four to
two what a wave of emotions in an 11 second
stretch there my goodness Quinn and Luke have
certainly done their level best to put on a show
for their respective teams yeah yeah good chance
for Queen oh flashes Le nice pass and theups
some early pressure here yeah I got middle I
got middle qu Hughes in drop pass Brock fesser
across pson to the m he scores boys good job
job good quick up let's get into this come on
win the battle win the battle hey switch it up
jailbreak jailbreak you're right there uhoh
here he goes oh ly oh ly get up get up get
up Miller shoots he scores again don't
turn off the TV now if you get the next
goal we can change the complexion of the
game and make Vancouver get a little bit
edgy we're going to take a shot of this we
got to score next couple minutes when the
pressure hits you got to stick with
the Staples Smith calling for it get
it it's a one goal game great shot KCK
have called timeout Rick toet wants to
settle things down here just got to relax
right trust the system trust the system
scan the ice play forward that's all relax
let's go all the pressure is on Vancouver
now he keep pushing eh let's keep going keep
pushing hey we're going to go timeout then
we're going six on four we got to stay on it
stay on him get on top of them and the Devils
pull the goal it six attackers boys don't
back off you got to go through guys I like
the grind yeah we gave up a couple of goals
he got back in then we to kill huge penalty
and we with the the storm there Dakota Joshua
CS towards the middle turns and he scores the
C Joshua ices it for the Canucks this game got
you closer to the edge of your seat as it went
along job boys I love it obviously more
special if Jack was playing but you know
me and Luke you know we'll enjoy it and
then hopefully we have lots of years like
this